[Music]
artificial intelligence is slowly
appearing in every aspect of our modern
lives it's in our smartphones of central
heating on our side boards and in our
cars but what about artificial general
intelligence that is the real quest the
aim to build an agent an algorithm that
can learn to solve any problem from
scratch without being taught how
welcome to deep mind the podcast I'm
Hanna Frey I'm a mathematician who has
worked with algorithms for almost a
decade in this series of podcasts we're
following the fast-moving story of
artificial intelligence for the past 12
months we've been tracking the latest
work of scientists researchers and
engineers at deep mind in London we're
looking at how they're approaching the
science of AI and some of the tricky
decisions the whole field is wrestling
with at the moment so whether you want
to know more about where technology has
headed all want to be inspired on your
own AI journey then you've come to the
right place now in the last episode we
were talking about how pitting
artificial intelligence against
world-class players in the game of chess
and the game of Go is about much more
than just showing off what a computer
can do human players can learn from how
the AI plays and improve their own play
as a result and there's also a bigger
picture the world of games provides the
perfect mini universe to try out
everything we want our artificial
intelligence to do but intelligence is
much more than just championing or logic
intelligence requires other skills like
the ability to collaborate I want to
introduce research scientist max ei de
Burgh max and his colleagues are trying
to work out how to train agents to work
together as a team so imagine this a few
decades in the future we have all these
AI systems out in the world doing
different things but they maybe have
never seen each other before there's
thousands of these things hundreds of
thousands each have their own objectives
but somehow they have to cooperate and
compete in a sensible way and in a very
ad hoc way in a way that they've never
seen each other before humans are really
good at this when we want to be anyway
even when we haven't encountered another
person before we still know how to
understand their intentions and how to
interact with them our agents of the
future need to be able to do the same
thing with each other we already have
things like Google home and these sort
of smart devices out there were probably
have more and more of those and you can
imagine them having to interact and work
with each other and one device may not
have ever seen another device before but
they still somehow have to interact and
get things done whew are we talking
about like your your Google home and
your dishwasher here this kind of stuff
oh yeah potentially you know your
dishwasher might want to actually go on
its cleaning cycle but Google home wants
it to you know clean all the dishes and
say what's best for you as the person I
donate and who gets to decide just as a
side who rules supreme your dishwasher
your Google assistant yeah I don't know
there's an important distinction here if
you've got a smart light bulb that you
could program to come on at six o'clock
in the evening that is an algorithm if
you've got one that can learn your
preferences that can understand when you
like the lights to be dimmed what kind
of mood lighting you like when you're
reading that is a I but as we switch
away from building things that do rigid
pre-decided tasks we're asking our
technology to read the situation and
react to what's going on around it and
in the long term that's going to require
collaboration so in the spirit of trying
things out in a toy universe the team at
deep mind have been trying to find
inspiration in another kind of game one
taken straight from the school
playground this is capture the flag you
know the deal the first team to steal
the flag of their opponent and bring it
back to their own base wigs if you get
tagged by the opposition then you're out
of the game oh come on don't cry max
dropped whole populations of AI agents
into a digital version of the game this
is an on screen version you sort of you
just see your first-person point of view
so you have to sort of look around and
move through this 3d world from your own
first-person perspective but interact
with these other things which see their
own first-person perspective so here
there's no centralized entity or being
that can see no army commander every
player acts independently
they only see their own observation and
the way we train these things we
actually train whole populations of
teammates you know let's say 30 agents
in parallel and they're all playing with
and against each other rather than just
creating a single agent Max and his team
build an entire classroom of them 30 in
total and for each round of the game he
randomly selects a few of the agents
from the class to play together on a
team by doing this thousands and
thousands of times each agent will learn
from their own experience but because
they're playing with each other - with
their classmates as it were they have to
learn to interact with someone who's
different from themselves the problem is
when we start they're actually just all
very random they're just bouncing about
the place without a clue and then one of
them will discover something and will
start actually let's say taking control
of the flag and actually scoring points
and at that point there's evolutionary
pressure on this population
and here's the clever bit max and his
team aren't just letting the agents in
the classroom play on and on forever
they're also using something called a
genetic algorithm a way to make sure the
whole culture of the population of
agents evolves so they're actually that
some of the weaker ones will be removed
from this population so it's almost like
you're making that population of 30 have
children yeah absolutely breeding them
together yeah
the original classroom of agents breed
together and have kids of their own and
as you go down the generations the
strongest traits survive but unlike
human children when an agent has
children in this setup they inherit
everything they inherit the knowledge
that's been gained from their parent but
you're mixing up their characteristics
as you go from one generation to the
next yes so this agent has to learn to
play a five-minute game of capture the
flag which is really you play five
minutes you do thousands of actions and
you just get a win or a loss and whether
you won or lost the game and somehow we
have to learn what to do with that and
so to help bridge that problem we have
this idea of internal rewards where
there are events in the game such as
picking up a flag or dropping a flag or
your teammate tagging an opponent or an
opponent tagging you all these sort of
things and we allow the agents to
individually evolve their own internal
rewards which is the reward they
assigned to each one of these events so
some agents are going to care a great
deal about grab hold of the flag and
other agents are gonna care a lot about
teammate tagging someone yeah this kind
of evolutionary group training means
that they can assume different roles
producing better results for stealing a
flag and with a bit of practice after a
few thousand rounds a teams of agents
become really rather good at this game
the absolutely smashing the great thing
about training an agent in this manner
is that they're robust yes they can play
themselves but they can play other
agents that have been trained in
completely different regimes they can
also play these in-game BOTS which are
sort of these hard-coded bots that ship
with the game but most interestingly
they can also play with people so you
can drop people into these games and
have you know an AI teammate or AI
opponents
what was it actually like to play with
an agent men to me does it feel like
they are getting what you're going to do
as well as doing their own thing it
feels less like they're guessing what
you're doing and more like they
completely ignore you in their very
ruthless humans pay a lot of attention
to other humans even in game scenarios
like humans will fixate on the other
players
the game but these agents have been
trained completely unbiased without
these sort of human biases your opponent
will run right past you and not even try
and tag you because they're so fixated
on actually getting the flag as quickly
as possible because that's what's going
to maximize their number of flair
captures and win them the game things
that really annoying human players would
do there's a kind of magic going on here
initially researchers are working on
these agents trying to see a way through
the muddle then there is that
breakthrough moment
when the agent gets it when they start
to behave like you think they should let
me tease you with care I cover cholo
director of research at deep mind I
remember training agents in the early
days the first time actually those
agents started behaving like okay it's
an environment it's trying to navigate
and strength to avoid certain obstacles
and whatnot the first time it starts
doing that it's actually it is nice it
is like it's it's quite fun to see that
because you know that it makes the
decision for itself I think knowing that
you have created an algorithm that can
take decisions I think that aspect is
quite enjoyable that is very
satisfactory it's worth remembering that
these games aren't just a trivial
pursuit for deep mind they've invested
in this rigorous training for a reason
they want to see how an AI develops
these kinds of skills for itself we
spend a lot of time in this
capture-the-flag work looking into the
the neural networks of these agents to
try and understand what they care about
and how they represent the game world
and what was really cool is that we
found that the agents actually had a
really really rich representation of
this game world without being told
anything about the game world itself you
know these agents just look at the
pixels of the screen yet somehow they've
clustered their you know internal
activations into things like oh I'm in
my home base I'm in the opponent base
I've got the flag and I can see my
teammate ahead of me I'm looking at the
opponent flag carrier while my teammate
is holding our flag and you can even
find individual neurons which just
activates if for example your teammate
is holding the flag you can totally
understand
how the agent is seeing again as you go
through I'm not sure about totally
understand but we're really getting an
idea of what is being represented
strongly of what isn't being represented
strongly
maxi's ages are using something called
neural networks it's a type of machine
learning algorithm that is loosely based
on a simplified version of the human
brain layers on layers of artificial
neurons are connected together in a vast
network and fire information between
themselves by looking inside an agent's
electronic brain max can work out which
micro level connections are responsible
for what macro level behavior and this
could be hugely beneficial as AI becomes
more integrated in our everyday lives
the hope is that well into the future
we can start actually having agents
which can go out into the real world
interact with humans with other agents
without fighting without fighting
being sensible yeah not squabbling too
much unlike humans yeah exactly
[Music]
games without frontiers teamwork without
tears but there is a big leap between
board games or simple games like capture
the flag and the big bad world with all
of its complexity and messiness you'll
remember David Silva the man who brought
us alphago the agent that defeated the
world champion at the ancient board game
of Go well he's also involved in pushing
deep Minds AI into ever more perplexing
environments in the context of games I
think there is a further challenge which
is many people in the community are
moving towards which is to take the most
challenging computer game in this case
it's the game of StarCraft many people
in the AI community are viewing this as
the next grand challenge now how can we
actually devise agents which can play in
this very rich environment which has
challenges which are not only different
but many times faster than go in other
ways
this is deepmind the podcast an
introduction to AI one of the most
fascinating fields in science today have
you ever seen footage of those vast
eternal entire arena of dedicated fans
excitedly watches on in support of
highly skilled players sat on stage in
their gaming chairs armed only with a
keyboard a mouse and a computer screen
well chances are they are playing
something like Starcraft 2 created by
the American video game developer
Blizzard Entertainment
[Music]
it is a monumentally tricky tactical
game where you play as one of three
races the enigmatic Li named Zerg
Protoss or Terrans each player has to
mine resources build an economy and
acquire increasingly sophisticated
technology all the time trying to defeat
your alien opponents in a futuristic
rather bleak looking landscape your
field of view of the simulated game is
limited by a moving camera that you have
to operate and so there's no way to see
everything at once often you can't see
your opponent at all and it is played by
tens of thousands of people sometimes
for hefty cash prizes and the human
players are staggeringly fast the best
in the world can manage up to eight
hundred clicks in a minute feeling
inadequate definitely super cool that I
can work on one thing that has been
certainly a passion of mine in in my
teenage days meet Oreo venules a
research scientist at deep mind he is an
ex-pro Starcraft player and co-leads the
Starcraft ethic a deep mind as you
develop a new algorithm or a new idea
when you test it you actually see it
play better the game you you like so
that's very rewarding and very visual
right that you try something new and you
really see oh my god it's really
understands how this unit works
Starcraft is a serious business so
serious in fact that has now been
professionalized and for oriole that
proves it is a game that pushes human
intelligence humans found it interesting
so that means it's an interesting game
that challenges intelligence and
creativity in ways that we like that we
spend many hours playing so how good is
the AI at the moment then how well can
it play Starcraft it's better than any
AI anyone has ever built and it
obviously has learned from experience
not from someone knowing the game and
encoding some set of rules this is I
mean one of the most complicated games
we've ever tackled it's challenging kind
of our understanding
and our algorithms quite a bit the deep
mind team decided to see how good their
work-in-progress really was by inviting
two of the world's best Starcraft 2
players to take on their own algorithm
so let me introduce deep minds alpha
star the first artificial intelligence
to ever take on top professional players
it plays the full game of Starcraft 2 by
using a deep neural network trained
directly from raw game data by
supervised learning and reinforcement
learning your commentators are dan stem
Koski aka artosis and Kevin Vander coy
aka Rotterdam well first of all it's
really awesome to be here together with
you then we were both I think incredibly
excited to see how this evening on fault
I mean this is just so exciting that D
mind is doing all this taking on alpha
star in this benchmarking match is
German champion dario vooc better known
as TLO he's normally a zerg player but
he's playing as Protoss for this match
Kevin and Dan are excited maybe even a
Tartar hoover excited so incredibly
excited oh my god this is like the most
excited I have personally ever been for
a man can't wait to really break down
some PvP so this is alpha star this is
an AI that we don't know how good it is
yet but already we have some interesting
things happening now I'm not entirely
conversing with the Starcraft player
glingo here so I will just say that
alpha star stalkers are laying down some
sharp moves feels to me like so far
these attacks have been very well
planned by alpha star
and they're relentless it loves to
attack and in a matter of minutes is all
over well that is it the G G is called
the good game here from TLO and the
first game from alpha star against a pro
gamer goes to alpha star David Silva was
there ringside we have a team that's
been working on this and ramping up our
development over the last few months and
this represents a you know a milestone
where we actually for the first time
work saw an AI that was actually able to
defeat a professional player so we have
a quick word with our defeated
challenger TLO when I was practicing
most of the humans I played against
played very standard starcraft once
again i assumed after the first match
i'll probably have a good idea how to
play against civilization i did not next
up the main event alpha star versus
poland's finest gregor comment better
known as mana one of the world's
strongest professional Starcraft players
I need to hear what you're thinking here
because that looks scary
yeah alpha star like he's not scared
about the around so well if I would be
playing against a human player right
there nobody is going up that front I
should point out for those of you that
play Starcraft that these matches are
taking place under professional match
conditions on a competitive ladder map
and without any game restrictions this
version of alpha star could see the
whole of the game map at any one time
but otherwise played in a comparable way
to humans our goal is not just to defeat
these players alcohol is to do it in the
right way all right
and the result alpha star 5 mana nil
I should tell you that monoplane a later
version of the algorithm in the end and
one so all in all five one now to
understand how an AI could learn to play
Starcraft or even ours put me to the
test a match to the end mathematician
versus machine of course a quite funky
looking Mouse in front of me and a
normal keyboard and on the screen there
is a very mean-looking alien yeah a
process sort of like an elephant meets
always got fists I wouldn't want to meet
him in a dog no no you see my friend or
not he is you I use mana you're gonna be
the commander of this particular race I
quickly found out that there is a lot to
take in Starcraft is perhaps not for
beginners you have your worker bees
collecting resources for you and these
these are all I mean they're almost like
ant creatures right so running out and
grabbing crystals exactly and you need
to try and work out how your actions
will affect the game in future this is
not easy for humans to learn let alone
agents that have absolutely no context
no object recognition and definitely no
former Starcraft champion to hold their
hand enemy it's it's gonna be pleasant
you just came to kind of find you and
now you see what you're doing which is
absolutely nothing so far we have we
have done nothing part of the challenge
of Starcraft is that there isn't an
ideal strategy that wins every time
it's a bit like rock-paper-scissors in
that way the winning tactic will depend
on how your opponent plays but remember
you only have a very narrow field of
vision outside of where your camera is
pointing your opponent could be up to
anything because you don't see the other
player you must decide when am I gonna
see it do I already know what it's going
on and should I not go and Scout what
it's doing but maybe if I do that he
knows that I know and so on so forth so
these kind of imperfect information as
of sacrifise extremely interesting as a
player and it's gonna be testing our
agents to levels that we haven't seen in
any other game and then of course
there's sort of details that have happen
in the game that you must remember for a
long time
advice I should have listened to more
carefully perhaps we're being attacked
are we gonna die but I think this
discovery phase right where you would
now basically you would lose you get the
reward of minus one yeah and you start
again if I was an algorithm I wouldn't
be upset by losing I would just reset
and go again each time armed with a
little more knowledge but to even be
able to play Starcraft in the first
place to even be able to operate the
controls the AI had to master quite a
few transferable skills you've noticed
when you were playing that there were
some movements that were resembling what
it was like to maybe navigate the web or
like operate your laptop namely click
drag and click drag and drop like select
rectangles and moving the mouse maybe
combining Mouse with keyboard and so on
and we tried exactly the same agent the
same architecture absolutely everything
the same way the same code almost and we
chase we change the environment instead
of saying now here is a Starcraft please
play to win we said here is paint
Microsoft Paint as an environment
interact with it and I'll reward you if
what you paint looks like a face and it
actually worked so I think that's just
learning these basic skills of
point-and-click interfaces that apply so
mad in so many places the same agent
that play Starcraft control real faces
in Microsoft Paint
right and here the the point to be
clarify is not the same agent that was
trained to play stack up is the same
algorithm that can train to play
Starcraft can also train to do pain
put that same algorithm to work drawing
celebrities in paint and it can capture
all the main traits of the face clicking
and dragging the mouse to recreate shape
and tone and hairstyle much like a
street artist would it's the same
technique but if you will it's kind of a
brain that is blank and then this brain
can learn to do these or that or that
and then we kind of by acting in the
environment repeatedly and getting
reward the the brain weights or it gets
shaped to do these tasks or that task or
that task we are not yet at the point
where the same brain that's both like we
do but obviously that's one of the
things we we would be very interested in
tackling next as well because that's
stepping towards artificial general
intelligence I guess exactly and that's
that's what we do every day that is the
ultimate goal and it's a topic of
conversation that's never far away
whoever in this building you find
yourself talking to because the point of
getting AI to play games like Starcraft
or go is to enhance our understanding of
what intelligence actually is here's
Ryan Hansel from the deep learning team
we write programs we run those programs
those experiments where we might train
an agent to play a game for instance or
to solve a puzzle in a simulated world
and then we look at the results of that
it really is trying to understand this
puzzle of learning and representation
memory control in terms of actions that
a robot would take there's so many
complex parts to this big puzzle of what
is an intelligent being what is an
intelligent agent but if you ask people
what they think the future of AI looks
like it tends to be wrapped up in
something a bit more physical something
that comes complete with moving arms and
everything I think one natural challenge
for AI which many people are centering
upon would be to actually have an impact
on the real world in the guise of
robotics to actually see a robot which
is able to to move
to grip to manipulate to even have
locomotion in anything approaching not
even what a human does maybe even an
animal I think this this would represent
a major stride forwards more on that
next time if you would like to find out
more about the themes in this episode or
explore the world of AI research beyond
deep mind you'll find plenty of useful
links in the show notes for each episode
and if there are stories or sources that
you think other listeners would find
helpful then let us know you can message
us on Twitter or email the team at pod
cast that deep mine comm you can also
use their address to send us your
questions or feedback on the series but
for now let's nip out for a bit of air